well it has been a crazy 24 hours really
a crazy couple of days for hogwarts
legacy fans and there's a couple of
things you need to know if you're
thinking about ordering this game i
realize not everybody's on twitter not
everybody has been following this every
step of the way because it's just been
insane so i'm going to try to clarify as
much as i can for everyone if you are
thinking about pre-ordering this game
now i'm not here to tell you whether or
not you should pre-order that's up to
you i know a lot of people have chosen
not to pre-order games anymore for good
reason but if you 100 know you want to
pre-order hogwarts legacy for whatever
reason whether it's collector's edition
whether it's because you want to have it
pre-loaded whatever it may be there is
some information that you need to know
now it has been kind of a roller coaster
ride for the past couple of days it all
started with us getting that new trailer
at gamescom i would say it was met with
mixed reactions most people were excited
to see this kind of darker side being
shown off but then there was some
concern as well about the facial
animations and maybe some of the voice
acting but i feel like for the most part
people were excited by what they saw in
the trailer then we got the pre-order
details we were told they would be
showing off the collector's edition the
very next day which is something people
were very excited about and so that was
the high well then things started to go
downhill so much so that hogwarts like
as he has actually put out an official
statement which we're gonna get to here
in a moment but it all started to go
downhill with the collector's edition
reveal first of all i think people were
by and large pretty disappointed with
what was in that and again we haven't
seen it in person yet so we can't speak
to the quality of all of this but then
the price tag is really what upset a lot
of people and from there it just kept
going downhill they told us we would be
able to pre-order starting thursday this
was august 25th at 11 a.m eastern time
well 11am came and
nothing happened there was no tweet
everybody was refreshing gamestop best
buy amazon all the usual websites
refreshing the hogwarts legacy homepage
and nothing happened for a bit it took
about 10-15 minutes before the hogwarts
legacy website actually updated and they
added this pre-order now section which
is still live at the time of this
recording and if you click on that it
will take you to this page here where
you can choose your edition and then you
can also choose your platform and you
can also choose your store well the
problem is when this first went up you
could not pre-order the deluxe and you
could not pre-order the collectors
anywhere there were no retailers listed
so if we go into the collector's edition
here and i'm just going to choose the
ps5 version right now the only store
listed is gamestop well guess what if
you go to gamestop it's sold out across
the board currently unavailable
completely sold out for the collector's
edition i know james of expecto go was
actually live streaming this and you can
go back and watch his stream and see
this happening in real time him
refreshing the page but a lot of people
were having trouble there i was
fortunate enough to get a pre-order for
the collector's edition in through
gamestop but at the time of this
recording that is still the only store
that has came online for the collector's
edition now i saw some people reporting
that best buy very briefly was selling
the pc collectors edition however
according to the update on the hogwarts
legacy website here which who knows if
it's gonna update in real time when best
buy and other places at it it does not
have any platforms listed for the pc
collector's edition now things are
faring better for the deluxe edition
you're starting to see this on steam
playstation xbox all the usual places
amazon has the listing up for it but it
is not yet available for sale best buy i
was able to get a pre-order in for the
deluxe on best buy's website so you
might want to try there if you're still
looking but then all of this is easily
forgiven you know stuff like this
happens you're working with a lot of
different retailers things like this
it's natural and just when we thought we
understood the different editions of
hogwarts legacy and what was included in
each one shout out to fearless vodka
over on the harry potter game subreddit
who made this little graph that you see
right here i thought this was the most
simple way of showing off what is in
each version but this has now changed as
well because what we have learned and
this is kind of the big deal going on
right now and that is that the
playstation version any playstation
version has an exclusive quest which was
not communicated to fans beforehand
before pre-orders went live before some
fans were dropping 300 on an xbox
version that doesn't include the
exclusive quest i mean that is probably
the most mind-blowing thing there when
you think about someone on xbox or pc
which pc collector's edition pre-orders
that i have seen have not went live yet
but for anybody who ordered the
collectors on gamestop for xbox had no
idea at the time they were ordering this
that they were going to be missing out
on this exclusive quest but it's not
just the exclusive quest apparently
playstation will also be getting the
felix felicis potion recipe of course
fans know this is the liquid luck potion
which hey i think that's awesome that's
going to be included in the game but is
it going to be locked out for all other
players i mean will this be a timed
exclusive will it eventually come to all
of her platforms or is this exclusive to
playstation forever then to take things
even more insane apparently there is an
amazon exclusive there's an amazon
edition of hogwarts legacy now i'm in
the us this is not on the us store yet
but you can find this listing on the
harry potter game subreddit and so far
it is on the french and german amazon
websites so here is a link of that
website right here which i think is
actually a pretty slick looking hat
right here but then right here edition
amazon what is going on are more
retailers going to have exclusive items
that we don't know about yet well if you
thought it was time for hogwarts legacy
to say something officially you're not
the only one because just before i hit
record on this video they actually put
up this statement here and i think it
was very much needed it starts off by
saying we're aware of the confusion that
has sparked following the role out of
pre-orders and we acknowledge and
apologize for the frustration caused in
our community the team hears you and
we'd like to provide some clarity on
questions that have come up regarding
collector's edition availability
collector's editions are going live with
our retailers on a rolling basis and
links are updated on hogwarts legacy.com
as we receive them now see i'm glad
they're saying this now but this is
something that would have definitely
been helpful to know before 11am on
thursday reading on here for clarity
pre-order of the ps4 and ps5 editions
standard deluxe digital deluxe and
collectors will come with the felix
felice's potion recipe all playstation
editions will come with the exclusive
quest no pre-order is required to obtain
it more information around sony
exclusives is coming soon i would expect
it sony's big event whenever they have
it that's when we're going to get that
and i know a lot of people were kind of
worried does this mean that it's not in
the physical playstation version no they
make it very clear here all playstation
versions will be getting the exclusive
quest reading on here regarding some
confusion around the dark arts pack and
potential micro transactions there are
no micro transactions in hogwarts legacy
players with the standard edition will
be given the option to purchase the dark
arts pack in game separately at launch
if they would like to upgrade there are
no other items for purchase in-game good
to get clarity on that as well a
wizarding world account or wb games
account is not required to play hogwarts
legacy this came from something that
appeared on steam for a little bit and
then they took it down i think it
actually made a lot of fans excited
because it was like hey can we actually
link this to our wizarding world and
bring over our patronus wand all those
sorts of things and i actually still
wouldn't rule that out i mean they say
not required here but they don't say
that it's not possible if this is
actually happening i think this would be
something great to reveal on back to
hogwarts day next week and then finally
again we'd like to reiterate that we
understand the frustrations around the
experience for the community yesterday
thank you for your continued excitement
and passion for hogwarts legacy okay
first off can we just give mad props to
chandler wood and the hogwarts legacy
team on this because this takes a lot to
stand up and do this and yes they've
made blunders they've made mistakes
they're stepping up they're owning to it
now we as a community as a fan base
we're gonna give them a chance to right
this wrong and to be completely fair
here the whole idea of exclusivity i'm
not a fan of it but i get it i mean it's
part of the industry i understand it it
happens on both sides all the companies
do this this is a normal thing my
biggest issue is that it just wasn't
communicated beforehand i mean if they
had made this known beforehand before
pre-orders went live before a 300
collector's edition went live then yeah
it wouldn't have been nearly as big of a
deal what people have still been upset
absolutely now we still need to know if
it's going to be a timed exclusive but
playstation is probably going to try and
keep that under wraps for as long as
they can and then the other thing that i
have tried to remind fans of time and
time again is that with a property like
harry potter which i know this is not a
harry potter game but being part of the
wizarding world there are so many
different parties that touch this guys
this is way above just avalanche right
here there are wb is involved porky
games is involved avalanche is involved
playstation is involved and then you
have all these retailers involved as
well so there are a lot of moving parts
here and things like this just generally
happen now the good news about most
pre-orders is that the vast majority of
companies will allow you to cancel your
pre-order so if you have learned
something in this video that makes you
want to change your pre-order check with
the retailer you purchase from and you
can very likely cancel that pre-order if
you need to maybe you want to cancel and
wait a while i wouldn't blame you if
you're new here be sure you hit that
subscribe button before you go i will
keep you up to date on all the latest
hogwarts legacy news theories discussion
as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon